we are what we repeatedly do change
doesn't just happen at this level of
behavior but what you have to change the
environment make a damn schedule and
stick to it
what's that believe nation it's Evan
this channel is designed to be a part of
your daily success routine and help you
believe in your Michael Jordan level
talent so today let's live your best
believe life and learn how to use the
power of habits to achieve success also
if you want to learn what Mel Robbins
Peter boob Tim Ferriss and others have
to say about building unstoppable
confidence check out my 250 for
confidence series where every day for
the next 254 days I will send you a
morning video for free to help you build
your confidence the link is in the
description below
when you set goals when you have an
intention on something that you want to
change about your life your brain helps
you a lot of the anxiety that we feel is
actually due to using words that are not
defined very well and if you don't have
confidence you're always gonna find a
way to lose in entrepreneurship
[Music]
let's kick it off with rule number one
get good habits with Dan Locke we are
what we repeatedly do human beings we
are creatures of habits you notice that
you kind of do the same thing the same
routine over over and again and again
and again see become getting rich is not
an act it is a habit so it is staying
poor it's also not an act it's not
something just happens to you it is a
habit so let me teach you the three best
habits of rich people the very first
habit of rich people and that is they
count their money poor people don't
count their money they get a paycheck
they deposit a paycheck they spend the
money they have no idea what the
expenses are you have no idea how the
money flows you know this poor people
they all be they have a job and wait
till maybe once a year when they found
out they would text return is the Texas
that I own is how much of the pay they
look at the numbers they even look at
the numbers it's just okay all right
that's what how much I need to pay
without tax return and death yep look at
it maybe maybe once a year rich people
we don't do that we look at our numbers
regularly we are financially literate
I'm not a numbers person don't get me
wrong okay I'm a concept guy okay I'm a
big-picture thinker I'm a visionary but
I am very very careful and I'm very
aware how my money is flowing habit
number two is they pay themselves first
now you've heard of this before oh yeah
I know
then I've heard of this this before you
gotta pay yourself do you know actually
what that means paying yourself doesn't
even buy yourself a car
it doesn't mean taking that vacation it
doesn't mean that you know you would you
know you go blow money on entertainment
oh yeah I'm paying money myself
no that's paying everybody else when
you're buying a car you're paying the
automotive motive company when you're
buying a house you are paying the bank
when you are traveling you are paying
the the travel agency
Hotel you're paying the the flight
company airplane company paying yourself
meaning that you put your money aside
and you invest your money now I'm not
talking about being frugal you know if
you know anything about me you know my
work I'm not talking about being fool
girl and being cheap I'm talking about
taking a piss percentage of your income
and putting that aside pay yourself
first and save it and then you invest it
habit of rich people number three and
that is rich people are constantly
improving their earning ability because
you might be thinking Dan okay I want to
pay myself first but I'm not making
enough money I'm only making a few
dollars in a month i couldíve I couldn't
even afford to pay my bills
how am I gonna pay myself first first of
all you gotta have the habit of paying
yourself first if you're not paying
yourself first even a tiny small
percentage when you're making 30 40 50
60 $100,000 a year I guarantee you when
you're making a million two million
dollars a year you're not paying
yourself it is a habit that I'm talking
about and in order to do that in order
to be able to every single year to be
able to pay yourself more and more and
more and put into investments you need
to improve your earning ability you need
to find ways how you can add value to
the marketplace how to add more value to
the marketplace so every single year
your income is going up every year if
you've been you've been working in house
in the real world and you have your own
business and your income kind of stays
flat for the last 2 3 5 years then shame
on you it means you're not learning it
means you're not thinking it means
you're not growing every single year
your income you have to strive to
improve that your earning ability and
the rich people we're always constantly
looking for ways to improve our earning
ability but also looking for ways to ant
leverage to apply leverage into what we
do rule number 2 set up your environment
for success with Jim quick a lot of
people always want to make it usually
make a change on behavior they want to
get themselves to workout they want to
get them as a meditate they want to get
themselves to read more each day they
want to get themselves to X right or
they want to stop some behavior they
want to stop smoking they want to stop
eating this food they want to stop I
always tell people stop
can your phone the first hour of the day
I love and I and I just that's like
sacred time for me you know because I
for me that's for I think that if you
want to be an elite mental performer or
in a real-life superhero you don't want
to start off by checking the phone we
talked about this in the past because
you're training yourself to be reactive
right you're getting your dopamine
you're frying your nervous system with
all these likes shares comments and
everything else like that that you've
said if I'm not mistaken you sell your
sovereignty weed if you start by
checking your phone I love that so much
because you're reacting and firefighting
to everyone's like wow all at 50 and
everyone would want so you're not really
setting you're not living you know that
it's you've heard this many times right
if you want to you in the first hour of
the day to win the rest they don't even
with room in the day right and so
anything you want to stop so I say you
want stop checking your phone right in
the morning then there's certain like
that's a behavior right but there's so
many other elements to be able to change
because some most behaviors don't stick
right and so like what I'm thinking
about when I want to transform or
transcend or make a real positive change
I'm looking all the other areas of
ourself so I'm looking at for example
our environment are you are people
setting up their environment to win and
no social change doesn't just happen at
this level of behavior but what you have
to change the environment so for example
if you want to stop eating a certain
food it helps to be able to have not
that not have that food in your home
right so you change the environment if
you want to read more it helps to help
set up your environment or you have the
books readily available where you're
gonna read it because they perform you
know how I how I approach habit change
is this area of motivation and this
trigger right you want to trigger to
help and remind you to do the behavior
right so are you setting up the
environment in a way that triggers the
behavior that you want but not only the
the be environment it's like the when
and the where but it's also behaviors
also the capabilities because a lot of
people want to change a behavior but
they're not training in the abilities
that I love a lot about your work and
your passion is the area of be able to
like ability those acquisition new
abilities for yourself and also they
could also benefit the rest of world but
most people aren't training those habits
and there's capabilities rule number
three tweak your habits with Mel Robbins
I realized that I need to have a level
of focus and a level of an
tenshun ality that I have not yet
cultivated in my life that there still
that I do that I put in the way that was
fine when I was operating and achieving
at this level but now I want to go to
this level and so what are those things
getting up earlier being a complete hawk
about how I'm spending my time and
attention that in the mornings when I'm
with my family literally being hyper
focused on just them so that I'm present
with them and then confession I'll
literally work for like 25 minutes and
then the AED kicks in and then I'll find
myself folding laundry for 20 minutes
because I allow myself to get distracted
see that's the thing about habits and
the levels of success that you get to
that when you recognize that jumping to
the next level that you want to get to
is nothing more than just tweaking your
habits a little bit that it's really
that simple you will start to be able to
have quantum leaps and I'm realizing
that I have amazing habits but they have
gotten me to here and if I want to get
to the next level it's gonna require a
level of focus and intentionality that I
haven't demanded of myself before no
drinking during the week being super
super focused on the stuff that's really
important probably hiring somebody
full-time to be a full-time assistant to
help me stay organized and focused in
terms of scheduling and weeding through
all the incoming requests I think it's
just about that about this sort of like
maniacal focus on things that are
important like now is the time and
what's cool is you can make it happen
anytime in your life like if there's
some jump that you want to make look I'm
an extraordinarily productive person
I've accomplished a tremendous amount in
the last three years but what it's gonna
take for me to get to the next level and
not destroy the people around me with my
stress and be an amazing leader and be
an amazing mother and be an awesome wife
and actually be an incredible
businesswoman is a level of focus that I
have never required of myself rule
number four
break your old habits with Joe Dispenza
we have a huge frontal lobe it's 40% of
our entire brain and most people when
they have a thought they just think that
that's the truth
and I think one of my greatest
realizations in my own journey was to
because you have a thought that it
doesn't necessarily mean it's true so if
you think 60 to 70 thousand thoughts in
one day and we do and 90 percent of
those thoughts are the same thoughts as
the day before and you believe that your
thoughts have something to do with your
destiny your life's not gonna change
very much because the same thought leads
to the same choice the same choice leads
to the same behavior the same behavior
creates the same experience and the same
experience produces the same motion and
so then the act of becoming conscious of
this process to to begin to become more
aware of how you think how you act in
how you feel
it's called metacognition and so then
why is that important because the more
conscious you become of those
unconscious states of mind and body the
less likely you're gonna go unconscious
during the day and that thought is not
gonna slip by your awareness unchecked
because your it means to know thyself
and the word meditation means to become
familiar with so as you become familiar
with the thoughts the behaviors and the
emotions of the old self you're retiring
that old self as you fire and wire new
thoughts and condition the body into a
new emotional state if you do that
enough times it'll begin to become
familiar to you so it's so important
just like a garden if you're planting a
garden you got to get rid of the weeds
you got to take the plants from the past
year and you got to pull them out the
rocks that sift to the top that are like
our emotional blocks they have to be
removed that soil has to be tenderized
and broken down we have to we have to
make room to plant the new garden so
primarily we learn the most about
ourselves and others when we're
uncomfortable because the moment you
move into that uncomfortable state
normally a program jumps in when that
program jumps simms because the person
doesn't want to be in the present moment
and engage it consciously so when you
teach people how to do that with a
meditative process turns out that when
they're in their life they're less
likely to emotionally react they're less
likely to be so rigid and believe the
thoughts they were thinking they're more
aware of when they go unconscious back
into a habit and that is what starts the
process of change and so we have to
unlearn
before we relearn we have to break the
habit of the old self before we reinvent
a new self we have to pre synaptic
connections and sprout new connections
we have to unfired unwire and refire and
rewire we have to unmemorable
then recondition the body to a new mind
into a new emotion like the program and
reprogram that's the act and it's a
two-step process yeah I like the way
that you call that out as an action
there was another thing that you said
that I thought was really powerful about
how insights themselves are essentially
inert they don't do anything what what
then do we do with an insight how do we
take a breakthrough moment and make sure
that it's not just a breakthrough moment
like I guarantee people watching right
now are having like a hundred aha
moments for sure that was definitely the
case for me as I was researching you and
when you said that I was like and that's
the danger that you have the AHA and
then nothing yeah yeah and that's it's a
it is a danger because then people will
will shrink back into mediocracy and
they'll use the insight to excuse them
from taking a leap they'll say yeah you
know I have a chemical imbalance in my
brain and my father was really
overbearing he was a perfectionist
that's why I am the way you know people
they come up with stuff to to excuse
themselves the insight is actually
giving them permission to stay limited
and it's an amazing idea because they'll
say to you that they really want to get
over their anxiety but let's okay let's
take your ex-husband let's put them in a
straitjacket
let's duct tape them and shoot them to
the moon know what I mean what are you
gonna do now you still have to make
those changes and so then the person's
enemy dies or they're something shifts
in their life and that person's gone
they'll find another person to hate this
is just how we function as human beings
we just slide another reason to feel
those emotions so I think I think when
people start to understand this you know
I think knowledge is power but knowledge
about yourself is self empowerment rule
number five make a schedule with Jordan
V Peterson naked damn schedule and stick
to it
okay so what's the rule with the
schedule it's not a bloody prison that's
the first thing that people do wrong so
I don't like to have follow a schedule
looks like well what kind of schedule
are you setting up well I should I have
to do this then I have to do this then I
have to do this you know and then I just
go play video games because who wants to
do all these things that I have to do
it's like wrong set the damn schedule up
so that you have the day you want that's
the trick it's like okay I've got
tomorrow if I was gonna set it up so it
was the best possible day I could have
practically speaking what would it look
like well then you schedule that and
obviously there's a bit of
responsibility that's gonna go along
with that because if you have any sense
one of the things that you're gonna
insist upon is that at the end of the
day you're not in worse shape than you
were that then at the beginning of the
day right cuz that's a stupid day if you
have a bunch of those in a row you just
dig you know you dig yourself a hole and
then you bury yourself in it's like
sorry that's just not a good strategy
it's a bad strategy
so maybe 20% of your day has to be
responsibility and obligation or maybe
it's more than that depending on how far
behind you are but even that you can you
can ask yourself okay well I've got
these responsibilities I have to
schedule the damn things in what's the
right ratio of responsibility to reward
and you can ask yourself that just like
you'd ago she ate with someone who is
working for you it's like okay you got
work tomorrow okay so I want you to work
tomorrow and you might say okay well
what are you gonna do for me that makes
it likely that I'll work for you well
you could ask yourself that you know so
maybe you'd do an hour of responsibility
and then you play a video game for 15
minutes I don't know whatever turns your
crank man but you know you have to
negotiate with yourself and not
tyrannize yourself like you're
negotiating with someone that you care
for that you would like to be productive
and have a good life and and that's how
you make the schedule it's like and then
you look at the day and you think well
if I had that day that'd be good great
you know and you you're useless and
horrible so you'll probably only hit it
with about 70% accuracy but that beats
the hell out of zero right and if you
hit it even with 50% accuracy another
rule is well aim for 51% the next week
or 50 and a half percent for God's sake
or because you're gonna hit that
position where things start to loop back
positively and spiral you upward you'll
ever see
create routines with Tim Ferriss so
whether it's Jaco will Inc you mentioned
retired Navy SEAL commander used to be
in charge of all West Coast training for
the SEAL Teams which is intense highly
highly decorated whether Jaco saying
discipline equals freedom or you look at
say some of the writers or musicians or
directors or others in the book across
pretty much all of them you find that
they find freedom in constraints so what
does that mean it sounds kind of weird
it also sounds very it sounds like an
oxymoron lit and what I mean by that is
all of these people have routines they
have set recipes that they repeat on a
daily and weekly basis so that they are
not making a lot of extraneous decisions
about mundane things and they also
recognize that we all have our less
ourselves our impulses I love chocolate
croissants if it were if I left my
entire schedule to whim I would just eat
chocolate croissants all day long I love
them they're incredible and I still do
have them once a week my cheat day and
I'm allowed to do what I want so I let
my monkey mind and my lesser self just
go nuts
but these people all have typically
these and these are folks we might be
inclined to think of as superheroes and
maybe Jacko's a superhero but the vast
majority have one or two strengths they
may not even be the best of the world
but one or two strengths they combine in
a really unique way and they build
habits around those strengths and then
they have a thousand other weaknesses
but the habits and routines are what
helped them from going off the rails and
this is really encouraging this should
be really encouraging because the people
we see on magazine covers that we might
idolize and feel we could never possibly
emulate because they have it all figured
out
they'd have no insecurities they wake up
every morning and with a mental karate
chop they just master the day that's not
how it works I know these people almost
everyone in this book certainly on the
podcast I've become friends with
hundreds of these people
true they have tons of not everyone I
don't speak for everyone but tons of
neuroses tons of terrible self-defeating
habits and the safety that they create
is habits and routines that's why Jocko
in part says discipline equals freedom
okay so you have trouble waking up in
the morning no problem
you want to stage this is something
choco does takes his clothing prepares
gets this sort of coffee ready to brew
clothing on the floor for the workout
right next to his bed prepared the night
before so there are no decisions there
are no opportunities to make mistakes
between him opening his eyes and jakka
working out and you find this across
everybody everybody and rule number
seven the last one before a very special
bonus clip is enhance your good habits
with google politics I really want all
of you to truly truly introspect if
you've decided something in the last
year 2017 and did you truly work on it
through the year and where do you stand
today throughout the day today till we
meet the next morning tomorrow at eight
o'clock I want all of you to introspect
this one-word introspection to see if
you've actually worked on what you
decided or were you a victim of
resolution dissolution and no solution
ladies and gentlemen I often say with
habits are of three kinds the first is
our good habits and when we talk about
good habits for example saying a thank
you this is an example or saying a sorry
being hospitable courteous kind is a
good habit and very often it's just a
habit though very often we could say a
thank you or even say you're sorry and
not even mean it we go into the
autopilot mode and that's why we call it
a habit it's just in the autopilot mode
we say thank you we don't mean it
we may say oh sorry we may not mean it
and therefore when it comes to good
habits in the year 2018 let us
consciously enhance them not just
sustain and enhance those habits but
consciously enhance those habits which
is basically for example we see say a
thank you we mean a thank you Excel for
example if we say you're sorry we mean
as sorry as well they're good habits and
you could identify your own good habits
and make sure that we do not continue
them in an autopilot mode in the year
2018 so with the good habits we don't
want to be in the autopilot mode but you
want to consciously enhance the quality
of those good habits as we enter the
year 2018 now I've got a really special
bonus clip with Peter Voogd on how to
create good rituals that I think you're
gonna really enjoy but before that it's
time for the three-point landing
questions time to move from just
watching another video to actually take
an action in your business so here we go
question number one what habit do you
need to change right now number two what
can you change in your environment to
help you and number three how can you
make it a part of your regular routine
what I realized evan is inspirations
really short-term and doesn't really
last past the activity producing it
habits are what drive people's action I
go to seminars and I mean I've spent a
lot of money on personal development
because you want to invest back in
yourself and if you go to seminars
people spend like two three five ten
grand and literally five percent of them
if you catch them two weeks later are
the exact same person because they get
inspired but they don't put it into
execution and what happens is they go
back to who they were so what I would
tell people is make sure you have a
daily routine that sets you up for
success so one my prizefighter routine a
morning routine that sets you up for
success first of all there's a lot of
stuff on morning routines that's that's
fine to have like a bunch of morning
routine stuff but I'm all about outcomes
so the whole purpose of a morning
routine is two things to get you in a
better state of mind to get you
confident and courageous to take on the
day and to to have intention and to know
exactly what you're doing that day so if
you just have rituals and here's what's
cool every frustration or every kind of
failure is because there's no rituals or
systems in place right so you got to
have systems for each area of your life
so for mindset you got to have a ritual
every week for productivity you gotta
have a ritual every week so let me give
you an example so if you want a mindset
ritual you have to have non-negotiables
in your schedule that you do no matter
what no matter how you feel you start
making decisions based off standards and
values not emotions or feelings raise
your standard Apple at the core is core
values
is that we believe that people have
passion can change the way people not
one drop of my self-worth depends on
your it's suppose to mean
if you guys like this video and want to
learn how to stop wasting your life away
check out the video next to me I think
you're gonna enjoy it continue to
believe and I'll see you there
99.9% of the people that watch or listen
to this content are living in the middle